Is Regis Rice a good supplement for someone with high cholesterol instead of a prescription drug?
Would you recommend something else? I know this is not cancer-related, so I understand if you'd rather not address it.
At what point would you say the right is not working for someone with cancer and would you recommend?
And what would you recommend instead? Frequency-wise, I should have said those two questions
into two different slides. But red yeast rice can a person use that for high cholesterol? Yes you can.
What other things could you use for high cholesterol?
Bergamit works good for high cholesterol. Burmareed even works for high cholesterol.
But yes, red yeast rice is something that some people have tried it and it works well for high cholesterol
and some people have tried it and said that it doesn't work and they use Bergamit or a combination of different things
in what works best for them. They have to kind of trial and error.
Now we do have to define what high cholesterol is too. So if a person's would I treat someone, would I treat?
Would I recommend a supplement for someone when what level of cholesterol do I have to get to recommend a supplement for that cholesterol?
Now typically you have to ask the question, why? So if I do a blood test and my cholesterol is 256 percent,
would I recommend a supplement for that? No, I wouldn't. Is that high cholesterol? Well again, it depends on the person.
So always when you're looking at blood work, you're looking at trends. Let's say this person or their whole life,
they had cholesterol of 160 and now their cholesterol is 256. Then I would say yes, that's high cholesterol for that person.
But again, so would you just use red yeast or would you use Bergamit or no, you get you asked the question, why?
So why do I have my cholesterol? Is my liver irritated? Is my liver congested from some reason?
So do I have arterial dysfunction? So remember, what are the things that will increase the person's cholesterol while a poor diet?
Well, that really, I mean, indirectly a poor diet. Well, I eat too many things with cholesterol. That's what my doctor said.
No, that's not what you're getting clustered. So even if you ate bacon every day, because there aren't a lot of cholesterol or whatever,
that's not going to give you a high cholesterol. Now, if you eat a lot of toxins and chemicals, that could give you a high cholesterol.
Even if there's toxic, these clinical stone-emity cholesterol in it, how would that happen? Well, any toxins and chemicals are going to congest your liver.
And when you have a congested liver, you're going to make more cholesterol to help lubricate your liver cholesterol in fact.
And making more cholesterol to help cleanse your liver could be one reason why a person has high cholesterol.
So you're asking the question, why is it because my liver is toxic? Could be toxic from liver flux, too, which is a parasite.
I've had people do parasite cleanse and their cholesterol goes down because they had liver flux.
Second reason why a person has high cholesterol is that they have high homelessness levels.
So they have high inflammation, which damaged their inner thelial air, which we discussed before.
Remember the inner thelial air is the single layer of epithelial cells that bind with vessels.
And if there's damage to those cells that damage to the inner thelial air, your body will make more cholesterol because the purpose of cholesterol,
one purpose cholesterol is to plaque the arteries to to to break to catch that damage.
So that could be a reason. So you have to address the reason why we're just going to take a drug or take a supplement to reduce cholesterol and not address why cholesterol.
That we could leave the patient to the worst situation.
Now, the better thing to do is to do, you know, multiple things at the same time, treat the reason why and try to lower cholesterol.
If that be the case, now typically cholesterol, you know, 252, 72, 280, and my book still isn't high, unless again, that patient had a trend that was much lower.
You know, a year ago, and now it's jumped way up.
When I graduated from school of cholesterol, normal cholesterol was 250.
So 250 and below, now they keep lowering it. Why? Because they have statin drugs that they can prescribe and make a bloody fortune on.
And so they have to lower the normal so that they can get more people on the drug.
That's a cynical thing to say, Dr. Cutters, you're just being mean to these drug companies.
I'm sorry, but the truth sometimes is greater is crazier than fiction because that's actually the true.
That being said, do you want to look for the reason why always.
And not just treat the value, the blood failure.
So again, okay, we could take a stat drug and your cholesterol goes back to normal.
Did you fix the reason why the cholesterol was high? I mean, to me, no, not at all.
So, I mean, we might as well have just, you know, crossed out that value on your blood test.
Oh, 350, that's too high. Let's just scribble that out. Let's just write in 220, 220.
Okay, there. Still then fix the problem doing that either.
So, whatever it is to make, if you artificially lower a blood value, if you artificially change a blood value with the drug without treating the reason why the blood value was there.
It's just, it's just as beneficial as you scratching out the number and writing it or whatever number you want. Oh, there, no imperfect.
That's very silly, but it is true.
So, think of that. So always digging to the reason why.
This is other question is a separate question. So let's dress it.
At what point would you say that right?
Is not working for someone with cancer and would you recommend something else instead frequency lines?
Okay, so if the person's cancer is continuing to grow in you and that everything you possibly can with right technology and you've done everything you possibly can.
With nutrition and changing nutrition. Now, my promise to you is not to anybody's not that I could make persons cancer go away, but I promise is always that I'll never stop trying.
So we need to tweak things. So you need to constantly be tweaking things.
Now, do you ever suggest other frequency devices? Maybe is the question.
Absolutely. There's other frequency devices that can help to PMF can help. There's other different therapy devices that can help with cancer.
There is other different therapy metabolic therapies like, you know, IV therapies and things that can help with cancer. So the current person's cancer is continuing to progress.
Then, you know, the worst thing that you can do in my book is to not communicate with me so that you're I've never going to shame you or never going to think that, oh, it's your fault or it's my fault.
It's, you know, it is what it is. We just have to be a realist and we need to tweak things and if I'm not the person who can apply change and we'll find somebody else that can apply change.
My purpose is only to help you. So if a cancer is progressing with everything that we are doing, then we have to do something different or seek for something different.
I will give advice where that's where sometimes I tell people we need to do chemo or we need to do radiation or we need to do whatever.
So, absolutely, just be open with me and never think you're offended me in anyone.